get get out of here
hey sebastian before you go you're free
to leave and everything
you have anything on you that would uh
drugs guns bombs anything like that
real quick
i don't think you can i'm asking no no
what do you have inside your bag
just
some stuff that i need to get home okay
you might show me
no i don't have to okay
thank you though nope next time i see
you here okay i i see it it's a jar and
it's got a little bit of weed in it okay
you think i'm done finished it okay
is that what's inside your bag yeah
that's it
just the wheat yeah okay take off your
bag
don't resist you're gonna make it a lot
worse than you need to take off your bag
sir please
don't make this worse
get get out of here get out of here
signal
43. signal 43 signal 433 follow me white
male white hispanic male running he's
going towards millennium boulevard he's
got a gun he's just shot at me
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's running he's going towards he's
going towards millennial convoy hotel
mic
white shirt blue jeans he got a black
hand
a bag he pulled out black signal zero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
he just crossed conroy right now he's
got to be somewhere around here
i'm in a football shoot with him
[Applause]
set it up
stop go
holy fuck
bitch just shot at me
yo
he must have just crossed somewhere
around here
he's a hotel mike
black hair no facial hair tattoos
white
he's got tattoos all on his right arm
where are you
i'm at conway and water garden water
garden
hey he's showing us right now
he's got that island
[Applause]
garden